why is America so Robo phobic we need to
get Americans figure they can rally
behind give your mom a kiss my baby too
slow boy we're gonna put a man inside a
machine thought it was incredibly
intelligent and it makes so much sense
to bring back this franchise it was a
sci-fi movie in 87 now it's reality we
have drones fighting wars for us we soon
have robust replacing soldiers and then
police officers and this creates a lot
of questions time to wake him up sir is
this it's not it's you the hell did you
do to me we wouldn't want to film on
imax mighty big called me from los
angeles from imax and told me man you're
gonna go crazy when you watch it make a
more practical let's go with black so
you're gonna see on a messy
big beautiful screen beautiful work body
control p.m. too late vs Tin Man office
I had no idea what a difference it would
make and how much more visceral exciting
immersive seeing this movie in imax i
have 20 seconds to comply with you so
sum up the film in five seconds it's a
badass smart emotional he's turned it
right now quick oh man look a dark
cynical look at the future one of those
rare filming it's a big scale action
movie about a man who wakes up to find
out he's become a robot that's right
he's coming thank you for your
cooperation
they're all I you're coming with me I
really want to see it in the big screen